this is the bust of Rhymes that none of
us have ever seen before Buster Rhymes
says it himself this is a buster Rhymes
that nobody's ever seen
before you will walk away from this
conversation understanding not only what
it takes to reach the very peak of your
powers but to stay there for 33 years to
have the insane consistency discipline
dedication and in his words addiction to
something that will take you to the very
top but then also you'll see the forces
in life that take you from that Peak to
the deepest depths of darkness and once
you're in that
Darkness how do you rise from it how did
Buster take himself from the darkest
moment of his life that he's really not
talked about ever before back to the
peak of his
powers this is a human story it's one of
the most inspiring stories we've ever
had on this show and it's a side of a
guy that we've known for many many
decades that I have never seen before
thank you to bust for this conversation
and if you like this conversation if you
like what we do here on the D of Co
before we get started I've got a
10-second favor to ask you about 62% of
you roughly that listen to this podcast
frequently haven't yet hit the Subscribe
button so if you can hit that subscribe
button it is the reason why we're able
to get guests like Buster rymes to come
here and have these conversations with
me I feel like we're a team here give a
little take a little so if you could hit
that subscribe button that would be
absolutely amazing it's the only favor
that I'll ever ask from you and I
promise you in turn that I'll do
everything to give you more guests like
this one and guess that you love enjoy
this
[Music]
episode Buster sometimes I think that
with maturity and with age we're able to
look back at our earliest years and
connect dots that only our maturity and
only our own growth and development
allow us to connect and those dots
sometimes indicate to
us why and how we became the person we
are today and that's really what I'm so
compelled to understand with you is what
is that early context that you look back
on now when you go the reason I am the
man I am today sat here is because of
this early context and these things and
these people what is that honestly have
to say it starts with my mother and my
father
um my mother and my father was was
strict you know what I'm saying and they
also made sure that I didn't need for
nothing I was able to really enjoy what
it was to be a child
and you know I don't I don't have to sit
here and and mislead people like I come
from some poor struggle and I come from
this this hood [__] like yeah I was in
the hood I was in Brooklyn East Flatbush
Brooklyn New York and I was in the hood
with enough of the the goons and the
Hooligans but
the difference about our era and the way
you mostly hear artists try to portray
it now is even the guys that was the
goons and the gangsters and the
troublemakers in the street they had
respect and they had integrity and they
understood what it was to have proper
manners
like if my
mother as serious as she
was saw any of the other kids in the
street it was the like I'm giving you an
example of how it really literally took
a village to raise a child like none of
the Neighbors on the Block would see
another child that they watch grow from
a little boy into becoming a teenager or
something and see that kid misbehaving
and not reprimand him in the street even
if they not his parent so my neighbors
had permission to to bust my ass if I
was misbehaving and then they would tell
my mother and if my mother felt like I
misrepresented her to make another
neighbor have to discipline me that was
going to get me another ass beaten so
you ended up getting two ass
beaten for every one trouble that you
caused you know what I'm saying and and
that's that [__] was important because I
think that as a community that [__] is
something that's it doesn't exist
anymore you can't tell no nobody else
kid nothing kids ain't trying to listen
to you tell them nothing they'll lift up
something and fling it after you or or
or go upside your head if and disrespect
you because there just a totally
different value in the way things are
done in the community so it starts with
my parents and the way I was raised in
it in the house to have respect for my
parents have respect for my other Elders
even if he wasn't my parent and
also even if you was dudes that was in
the street you still an elder we had to
respect you as an elder in in return
that same respect that came from the
house and you whenever you went abroad
and you conducted yourself in that
manner it would garnish the same respect
in return so even if it was a dude in
the street on some Street [__] the
respect that you showed to that Elder
still warranted a certain respect from
them they wouldn't disrespect the
respect that you was raised in your
house to have for your family and for
them so that respect was upheld and it
was that that integrity was defended
and that was a real
solid foundation that all of the other
flaw was built on which eventually
evolved into becoming a skyscraper for
me so I'mma start there with the kids
then I'm I'mma go to the neighborhood
because again when my parents was around
I got the same disciplining from the
neighbors the hardworking middle class
families the less fortunate families
that was still in the neighborhood we
all was on the same Accord about
discipline and respect was was it was it
easy to see when you look back how you
could have gone another way in that
context absolutely because all of those
things were still there the drug dealing
was still there the shootings were still
happening the robberies were still
happening all of that was there right
but the beautiful thing was there was a
serious presence of
balance that was just as impressionable
as all of the things that was the
negative presence that was strong and
that did get a stronghold on a lot of
the youth in the community at the time
too how come you didn't go the other way
I
did I did I just was fortunate enough to
have something like hip hop that was
able to be an alternative that saved my
life changed my
life and I had some incredible people
that was around me to
support me when I
found this interest and and I identified
with my gift as
an artist to be able
[Music]
to entertain
people
perform articulate my thoughts through
song and Ry
form and I had an incredible support
system with my moms I had an incredible
support system with just the other
friends and family that I grew up with
that was in a community and then last
but not least the determination that I
had to want to be able to not disappoint
the people that I knew that really was
proud of what I was doing good bad or
indifferent who
they it was it was all of them all of
them right so for example I pissed my
mom's off when I decided I wanted to
start selling weed and selling crack
right and the guys that was in the
street that I was doing it
with when they realized even though I
was doing and it was cool for us to do
it they didn't really want us to do it
when they started to see that we had
potential to do other things that was
going to keep us safe and keep us away
from the street a lot of the time they
didn't have a better opportunity to
offer us so they made sure that they was
as present as they could be to gu us
through the [__] that they didn't even
want us to do in the first place which
was the the stupidness we was carrying
on with in the
street so they did everything they could
to minimize the [__] that we would
get into so we don't get killed so we
don't go to jail so you know none of
that [__] would happen but once they
realize they didn't have a better
opportunity for us that is what they
felt was the best that they could do if
they if we're going to do the [__]
we got to be there to protect them and
make sure that they straight and we
guide them so that they could do it the
best way with the least amount of
[__] as a younger as a younger kid
right when they started to see that this
rapping thing and this hip-hop [__] and
break dancing and graffiti and DJing and
all of that [__] was something that we
started to generate interest for that's
when they started to encourage us to do
that more instead of cracking instead of
selling the drugs instead of selling
weed instead of stealing this and taking
that and so they were so happy to see we
found another way they wanted us to do
that so the more we did
that if we started to show them in
indication as we was making progress
that we wasn't continuing to be
productive now it felt like you was
pissing off two sets of
parents I'm already pissing off my
parents because I'm with them in the
street now they see me doing this music
[__] they like that [__] they proud of
me so if I'm not doing well in that now
I'm disappointing them too what was the
consequence of your parents separating
at 11 years old because I think about me
being 11 years old and I remember a
conversation my mom my mom's Nigerian I
was born in bwana my dad's English right
I remember at around that age about 10
years old my parents calling me in and
basically telling me they didn't love
each other anymore and it was like the
world had broken in half yeah it's like
you can't comprehend the concept of
these two people being separate like
being torn into two pieces how was it
for you at 11 years old when you find
that out it was disastrous for me
because um like you said you can't
really ever wrap your head around that
as a child you don't know how to
conceptualize that like
um obviously there was things that I was
able to do and and it was enjoyment I
was able to have when I spent time with
my father that I I couldn't get when I
was with my
mother there was things that I was
always able to get as far as nurturing
and being cared for and being baby for
my mother that I couldn't get from my
father and obviously divine order is
Mother and Father to make baby right
so I definitely didn't want to
lose neither one of them did you change
I definitely changed because um I wasn't
um I couldn't figure out how to find my
my my
uh the the the behaved kid that I was
even though I was still getting into
[__] the the [__] really started
once my mother and my father got a
divorce the misbehaving really started
picking up the the disrespect started to
pick up and intensify the anger was just
a lot
more why it overwhelmed me more because
I was just I wasn't happy with my
situation and then I wasn't happy
with the the way that I was directly
impacted by their beef so
like you know there would be times
when if my mother and my father wasn't
getting
along fresh discrepancy between the two
of them say like the day my father
posted to pick up me and my brother cuz
I only got one younger brother and say
he posted to come and pick us up on this
day and particularly for his visitation
weekend if a
argument started with the two of them
that
morning you know my father would get to
the house and then my mother wouldn't
even let us go and we would look and see
him in the front of the house from the
window
and my mom's would just be on some
[__] how did you feel looking at him
from the window it was [__] crazy you
wanted to go I'm guessing of course you
know what I'm saying because there was
things and there was other family that
obviously was on my father's side
cousins and kids from the neighborhoods
of the
cousins uh part of Brooklyn or queens
and different areas of New York that we
would go that we had friends and
with the family and with the
neighborhood friends that we met through
our other family and other cousins and
things of that nature in a different
neighborhood we we we wouldn't get to
see these people until Dad came to get
us because Mom's wasn't cool really with
that side of the family like that my
father's side of the family wasn't
really rocking with my mother's side of
the family like that so if that rotation
didn't happen in the visits we didn't
get to enjoy that we missed our dad we
was only
getting the opportunity to see him you
know once a week once every two weeks or
sometimes once a month if they they
beefing with each other did did your
relationship with your father at that
point kind of become a bit straighted
when because of that beef did you start
to see him less and less and less yeah I
I think my conflict with my father it
started to happen more and more because
um you know obviously
[Music]
um the lack of a parent presence has an
effect in different ways
right and as a son I don't know what it
is but I just think
instinctually boys cling on to their
moms
more I don't know if that's always the
case but in most cases that's usually
what it is I think my father's
personality was a little conflicting for
me with the way my personality was and
and the contrast of my father's
personality as opposed to my mother's
personality it it drew Conflict for me
too because my father he wasn't as
interested in the [__] that I wanted to
do or that the [__] that I was
interested in as a as a child like he
always was more serious
about whatever he felt was best for my
future was all that mattered it wasn't
about what I thought it was about what
he thought so I always started to feel
like in in having the comparison and
seeing the contrast between that and how
supportive my mother was for the [__]
that I wanted to do like you
know first time I got some [__] I could
come tell my mother I could sit down and
tell my mother about how that felt you
know what I'm saying I could sit and
tell my moms
about you know my first wet dream or
some [__] I could I could talk to my
moms and about the music that I'm making
in the studio with with my creu leaders
of a new school at the time and I could
come home and I could play that [__] in
the house I could turn up the [__] just
as long as I could do just as long as I
did what I was supposed to in the house
my mother was with all the other [__] as
long as it was productive and it kept me
away from the trouble in the street that
was relieving for her my
father you tried to talk to him at the
time about some rap [__] he's like I
don't want to hear that [__] that [__]
is a bunch of
[__] and you wasting your time with
that [__] that's how I used to talk you
know what I'm
saying now at that time I didn't respect
it and at that time I I I I felt a way I
felt real [__] up about that because
it was just
like I could be doing some real [__]
like I'm I'm actually still one foot
in because I'm not I'm I haven't
succeeded at this this [__] don't make
me no money I do this [__] cuz I love it
like I just love it so when I'm able to
do [__] that I love with with my friends
that and with my people
that I'm entertained by doing it with
them it's because I have this thing with
a crew that there's a
collective enjoyment that we're getting
from doing this music [__] are you still
trying to prove him wrong to some degree
did you find yourself trying to prove
him wrong then nah because I got my
opportunity to do it but before that
moment before at that time yeah
absolutely I was trying to prove him
wrong I was so determined to prove him
wrong that it it it it forced me to
excel because the more that he wanted me
to do what he wanted me to do which was
my father was a licensed electrical
contractor okay okay so
he used to force me to come to work his
way of keeping me off the street was
bringing me to work with him because he
had his
own company as a licensed electrical
contractor how' you feel about that I
was disgusted with that [__] because we
working in these nasty [__] buildings
with rats and roaches running around and
[__] and it took childhood time for me
because I wasn't able to be outside and
play that's really what I wanted to do
and how old were you then 12 it started
a little younger than that but right
around 12 is when it got serious I would
say like around 10 years old was when it
started 12 is when it got serious
because my mother used to send us to
different countries every summer with my
father just so we could be able to
explore what it was like to live in
Jamaica for a summer with the family
same [__] with England my mother would
send us to England so when I
was around there was one summer we came
out here you were 10 I was like 10 11 my
brother was younger than me he's like
seven I'm staying in morham them time
and Preston and we went to karate school
here we went to Primary School here
and we was break dancing and I had these
cousins that used to named Samantha and
Michaela they used to take me in val
they used to take me to these little
clubs cuz they used to bring us to like
this little area where it was like a uh
I wouldn't call it a downtown area but
there was a area Like a downtown area in
the morom area and in a Preston area and
in a Blackpool area and we would go and
we would break dance out there with the
young kids that was from England and you
know we had our style of doing [__] from
New York and we we we was we was getting
we was some dangerous little
[__] now let me you know we was
getting busy we was making it happen we
you know we twisting up and popping and
all of this [__] so it was it was
something where we just became a part of
this break dance community and they was
always looking forward to seeing us we
would go out there like three four times
a week other people promoters they would
see us they started to book us to come
in the clubs obviously we're too young
to go in a club so they would let us
come perform 10 minutes 15 minutes and
then we would have to leave immediately
so we made a little money that way get a
little 10 PBS here for a show a little
20 PBS there for a show but this these
are the things things that we grew
around so when I when I was around all
of
this and that started to slow
down dad was like okay y'all ain't going
nowhere this summer you're coming to
work do I want to go to work no do I
want to be an electrician no do I want
to be [__] pulling BX cable through
sheetrock no do I want to be hammering
nails and then bang my finger no do I
want to see rats and [__] Ro
crawling over my shoes and my timbering
boots and I don't want to do none of
that and I'm watching kids riding up and
down and Pap a wheelieing on the bike
and music playing outside and I can't do
that [__] I was I used to be super angry
at that [__] every day with my father
what did you want to do instead I wanted
to rap I wanted to make music I wanted
to break dance I wanted to do all the
[__] that
hip-hop consisted of like I I became the
embodiment of hip-hop and it was the
thing that was my
excuse to not go to work why did you
want to rap well number
one I wanted to be the DJ first okay you
know what I'm saying the DJ thing to me
though I never really got good at it to
be the DJ I was able to do it but I was
never nice enough to become the
Superstar DJ and at that
time
the DJ was super important because all
of the groups had the DJ name so the
Grand Master Flash and the furious five
Jam Master J Run DMC like the DJ was
always the
solo it was like he was the big
shot so when I I couldn't I'm not really
the technology dude you know what I'm
saying so all of
this equipment [__] like it was just a
little little complicated for me and
then I actually became a MC by
accident and the interesting part about
that
was I caught two Chargers selling crack
by the time I was
12 and fortunately the laws was
different and I was a
minor
so
I didn't see no serious trouble but I
was definitely on my way to getting into
some serious trouble if I didn't if my
mother didn't say all right enough of
this [__] we got to get you out of
here that's when she took me from
Brooklyn and brought me to Long
Island when I got to Long Island that's
when I met
Brown C Brown from leaders of the new
school dink OD D from leaders of the new
school
Milo is my mother's sister's son so he's
my first Blood
cousin but before we brought in Milo it
was and even before we brought in Dinko
was it was me Dinko and another dude
named mystery mystery was hustling in
the street too but when we went to Long
Island now a lot of other families was
thinking like my mother they brought
their kids from Brooklyn too to Long
Island from Queens to Long Island from
the Bronx to Long Island so we left the
neighborhood which is the hood we was
raised in we left the hood to come to
the suburbs and still be around a bunch
of kids from the
hood you know what I'm saying so the
same [__] you was running from we found
a way to do the same [__] in these nice
neighborhoods now and here we come as
the generation terrorizing these
beautiful
neighborhoods
and we [__] these neighborhoods up
when you say you became an accidental MC
this is what happened I wasn't rapping
yet I was only break dancing I was only
popping and I was DJing a little bit and
I was messing around with the
graffiti I wasn't rapping yet so when I
move to Long Island I meet Charlie Brown
I meet
mystery
[Music]
and what ends up
happening
is in this junior high school now they
got like these lip sync contests they
got rap contests
and you know we now finally getting a
chance to experience what it's like to
have a be in school where you have
periods different periods in classes and
you in one class for 45 minutes to an
hour then the bell ringing and you
switch I got the hallway action
everybody talking [__] go to the next
class flirt with a couple of chicks on
the way to the next class so all of that
interaction and starting now puberty
kicking in crazy you know 13 years old
12 13 now you starting to get your
homeowners moving different
so obviously you're going through the
stage in your life now where you want to
impress everybody you w to you want to
be the cool guy in
school
so whenever you came to Long Island
from the five
burrows it was a thing oh that's the new
Kid From Brooklyn oh that's the new kid
from Queens oh that's the new kid from
Bronx that's the new kid from stat
Island so me being one of the new kids
from Brooklyn it created this
talk
and the rapping thing is happening
Charlie Brown was like the guy he was
like the the the number one rap dude in
school at the time
so one day I'm coming out of the
school and we get in the schoolyard and
you know some of the kids waiting on the
school buses some of the kids is waiting
to see you know the football game or the
basketball game after school there was
like a cipher that was formed in this
particular day and it was a big one
and it was C Brown rapping and two other
kids and then
uh C Brown was getting most of the
shine I walks over to the cipher
and I started
beatboxing right and
uh Brown he's he doing his rap [__] to
my beatbox or whatever and you know I'm
keeping the beat going for
him and then
um everything was smooth in the
beginning like you know he was just
raming everything was cool and you know
he's sounding
good and then I probably like a good 30
40 seconds into it he just started
disrespecting me so I'm beatboxing for
him and he dissing me and I'm I'm I'm
kind of like torn
between should I punch this dude in his
face or should I just keep beatboxing
and not be the party pooper of the party
energy that we have in here and you how
old I was 12 I was I was 13 now and I'm
saying to
myself I'm from
Brooklyn
and the mentality back then was
everybody from Long Island was [__] you
know it's the suburbs it's the green
grass it's the flower beds it's it's the
the the the nice
houses we come from from from Concrete
Jungle we come from projects we come
from struggle
so I'm looking at this dude and I'm just
looking at him like I'mma [__] you up
like in two seconds because you a [__]
to me but you disrespecting me in front
of all these people and if I don't do
something then they going to look at me
like I'm a [__] too
so as I'm getting ready to do something
stupid the rhyme stopped like he was
done
and everybody was biging him up and you
know I ain't want to look like a sore
loser even though there was no battle he
just chose to diss me for no reason and
I couldn't understand it cuz I'm like y
I'm here to support you right now I'm
giving you the beat and the whole [__]
the [__] you doing
long story short that was the
day I said all right I'mma go
home and I'mma write a rhyme tonight and
I'mma come back tomorrow and I'mma
[__] disrespect this youth in front
of everybody the same way he dished me
up in front of
everybody and the next day I came to
school I waited all day I ain't tell
nobody [__] we got back in that same
yard nice big crowd the next
day he raming again I started beat
boxing for him again like like like it's
the exact thing happening like the day
before so we going and I'm doing what
I'm doing and everything is cool and
nobody ain't got no clue cuz I didn't
say [__] to nobody about having RS
ready and the crazy [__] is when I wrote
my
Rhymes I was listening to a bunch of LL
Cool J [__] because at the time LL was
battling everybody on record you know
what I'm saying battling Kumo D battle
IC te battle you know he was just he was
the one that was trying to take
everybody head off and I was like yo I
want to come like LL so I could tear
this boy head off so I ended up doing my
[__] and somehow
it went from me beatboxing to
him and for him to me telling him yo why
don't you do a beat for
me and he was like oh you got raps ready
today like just do a beat let me just
try
something so he did the
beat and I started off the r on some
calm [__] and then when I started to get
into the disrespect lines that's when
the the whole thing just started to
happen on its own
like
my frustration and then me seeing the
people reacting to my
[__] the way that I wanted them to it
just made me more confident more cocky
more charismatic and that's when the
whole bust
RS thing started to happen and my name
wasn't even Buster rhs at the time I had
a [__] up rap name at the
time what was
it yo
my name was terrible yo my name at the
time I had two I had my name from being
a part of the FR nation of the Gods and
Earth which that name was cooler that
was Lord tahim right but somehow I
abandoned that to
become like the rappers that had
three-part names right is there a reason
you're not telling me I'm getting to it
I'm just trying to help with I'm setting
it up with the proper
prerequisite
so LL Cool J is a three-part name yeah
Jam Master J is a three-part name all of
the guys from The Fat Boys Prince Mary D
cool rock ski them dudes had three-part
names
right I changed my name to chill o ski
[Laughter]
that name is so [__] terrible I know
I'm sorry
bro name was terrible and you know
what's so crazy I kept that name for a
long time cuz I really thought it was
the [__] cuz I felt like chill OSI Chill
O ski bro terrible I know it's terrible
but I I I really was proud of like I I
got a three-part name like my favorites
and if you want to be like your
favorites you got to do the [__] that is
a
replication of your favorites and
then I destroyed Charlie Brown so
bad that at the end of that night the
end of that little battle that afternoon
after school he he just came over to the
side and was like
yo we should should be in a group
together and that's really the day that
I guess Buster Rhymes I guess it's a
catalyst moment the day Buster was born
you talked about how that kind of moment
helped you develop your style and your
charisma and the way you carried
yourself and from then till when you get
signed at 17 years old I'm curious about
what happens in that moment because
that's really you
know a lot of people at 12 years old or
10 years old or whatever want to be
hip-hop actors or hip-hop stars or they
want to be whatever they want to be
musicians but very very few make it to
the top table what happens between the
playground that day and 17 years old you
getting signed when you look back and go
it was for that reason was it natural
Talent is it hard work is it all of the
above it it's all of the above but the
first thing for me was the
addiction to the
reaction that I was getting from the
people and I was seeing it and how it
felt in real time
and just just just looking at the fact
that I came up with
something in my crib by myself in my
bedroom that was fueled by a
determination of wanting to defend
myself like a
fight and a lot of the
times I don't think I might have said it
like this I've said it before but I
don't think I've said it a
lot I don't know if it would have been I
had the same desire to want to be in Hip
Hop I had the same desire to want to Ry
DJ but I don't know if if that moment
didn't
happen I don't know if I would have
pursued being an
MC at that time it probably wouldn't
have happened I've sat here with a lot
of people um who are comedian and
entertainers and actors and the biggest
movies in the world and it's so
interesting to me that there tends to be
an early Catalyst moment where they
perform maybe in front of the family at
Christmas or on stage or whatever it is
and they get this reaction and in that
moment that reaction does something to
them on a psychological level which
becomes as the word you used is the word
I hear becomes this addiction yeah and I
often wonder to myself because a lot of
other people will experience that
reaction and not develop the addiction
so the reaction it appears to me is
doing something for those people that
they needed at that moment yes I needed
it at that moment I'm going to tell you
something it it actually happened before
that to want to be a MC happened in that
moment the addiction to entertaining
people that [__] happened when I was
like seven eight years old maybe maybe
even six six years old because where it
started for me initially was you know at
the time and particularly like I was
saying how the neighborhood was back
then and how we was raised in our house
back then my mother and my father you
know we had to go to bed at 9:00 on a
school night
and on the weekends when we was that
young we might be able to stay up until
about 10 o'clock but we still had to go
to bed by a certain
time when my mother had company or like
my father and they had like family and
friends are you know they just had their
little grownup get
togethers and they get to drink in a
little bit sometimes you know they so
entertained by each other's company they
forget to send us to bed at nine o'clock
they playing music and [__] and I used
to have to do things I would try to
creatively come up with ways to avoid
being sent to bed at
9:00 so when they playing music the
first thing that I would always get into
doing
is reenactments of Michael Jackson and
from the Jackson Five and James Brown
dance
routines so I used to do that [__] and I
was nice with the [__] split and
spinning around and [__] and just keep
carrying
on I'm doing all type of [__] and
I'm for hours until I literally would be
sweating through my clothes but it was
so entertaining that
sometimes the whole company that was
there for my family my mother and my
father they ended up cheering me on and
rooting me on to continue
and bigging up my mom's about how much
talent her son has and was it not that
feeling then that you were chasing
that's what it was first that's what I
was saying like I I wasn't thinking
about being know wrap it in but I I knew
what that feeling felt
like and I always wanted that
feeling and that feeling started in the
crib and then it translated into
me trying to get that attention in the
classrooms which turned me into a
jokester in the class so I would do [__]
to get the attention of the crowd from
the class and became like this class
clown dude and I would get in trouble
and [__] and then it translated from
That Into You Know Me break dancing and
doing all this hip-hop [__] because I
loved hip-hop and I was starting to see
what what was being created as a
movement and what was being generated as
an interest that was taken over like it
didn't matter what else was cool at the
time when hip-hop started to really
become that
[__] there was nothing more important
than knowing how to do something that
was a representation of hip-hop if you
was a graffiti artist and you was
[__]
dope you became something that was like
on a celebrity status level but that's
when [__] started putting
graffiti on clothes and everybody that
was involved with hip-hop or some kind
of representation of hip-hop became some
sort of celebrity so for me that's why I
wanted to learn to do everything in
hip-hop cuz I still didn't know what I
wanted to do the DJ [__] complicated the
break Dan and [__] I ain't like the
[__] bruises I was getting all the
time you know what I'm saying
and the graffiti [__] I was cool with it
but it was really when that situation
happened with me and C Brown that's now
when I found that I was able to get the
feeling of when I was this little boy
dancing for my parents and their company
and at the same time I was able to have
that Spotlight on me being the rapper
guy so it's like all of this [__] became
the thing that I started to
grow not only this appreciation for
it but I started to grow addicted to the
[__] that is what I was expecting in
terms of like I was just trying to
figure out the psychological reason why
you became so addicted to this cuz
listen I come from a background where
lots of my friends started rapping and
most of them fell off and then there's
like one or two of them that just beca
it became like their medication to some
[__] and I've always wondered why they
just like that individual just stuck at
it for all those years but in that in
that answer we have the um I think the
biggest addiction for me out of all of
it was to be able to
say to my
father I wanted to be able to experience
the day not knowing if it would ever
come but it was a serious serious thing
like I used to write this [__] on my
wall and just on a piece of paper and I
would stick it on the
wall and it would say one
day I'm going
to get a deal I'm G sign a contract I'm
G come home with so much [__]
money that I'mma Be able to tell my
father I told you so
that's all I wanted to be able to do and
I wrote that [__] and put it on the wall
and I would look at that [__] every day
and and there would be days still when
he would tell me I got to come to work
and I would look at that
sign and then I would see him outside in
the
truck and I walk out that [__] house
and I would be mad as
hell
angry and
what I do love about my father as I got
older is I
understood what he wanted he just wanted
to make
sure I wasn't wasting my time he built
this company he want to pass it down it
was love it's love it was he need his
son to
succeed I'm his pride and his joy and
failure is not an option with my father
and I guess where he came
from you know it's the same with my
mother my mother when I told her 18 I
wasn't going to University wouldn't
speak to me for years but she comes from
Nigeria she left school at 7 years old
she can't read or write today wow so I
was the only of her four kids I was the
only one that says I'm not going to
University right now she stood in my way
and said don't start a business etc etc
but in in my maturity I go she stood in
my way because she loved me absolutely
at the time and everyone goes a lot of
people go through especially sort of
immigrant immigrant kids and stuff
primarily yeah because that pain and
that struggle that suffering that they
come from that [__] ain't no that's not
this [__] that we was raised in that you
know me and you we obviously even if you
was born there you wasn't you didn't
spend your years there to to experience
the pain that they did so you come here
now you still don't know they struggle
they know though they never going to
forget and they obviously want the best
for their babies man my father came to
the Apollo to see us and this what made
him even more sure about disrespecting
me and disrespecting the rap [__] me and
my my crew leaders of the new school we
had an opportunity to perform at the
Apollo at amateur night at the Apollo
and we get up there and we got
booed badly booed one of the first times
you know when me and Charlie Brown
decided to form the group the guy
mystery that was with us originally he
got tired of the the weight there was no
real light at the end of the tunnel if
we was going to get an opportunity to
get a record deal he was selling drugs
in the street too he decided he wanted
to go back to the street and do that he
ain't want to be in a rap group no more
that's how room was made for Dinko to
get in the group cuz we still felt like
we needed to replace the third rapper we
got our Three rap dudes now it's me
Brown and Dinko and then I said yo we
need a DJ let me get my cousin so Milo
came and we ended up doing the show at
the
Apollo got bulled and my father was even
he was hitting me with the I Told You So
that night see I tell you y you waste
your time with this little idiot rapper
boy
[__] for come and work that's what I'm
going tell you for come to work so you
can learn some
stability and stop waste your time with
this rapper [__] that's how you talking
to me we Still In the Venue really we
ain't even leave he just beating me in
the head with this total
disrespect
but again at that time I I hated him for
it as we got older and I that day came
for me I got my my record deal when I
was 17
and what was it about you though was it
was it this was it the unique style and
the you had a completely different flow
that people were just drawn to that
raised the energy on every record what
you touched it definitely was that and
that came completely from dance hall
influence right
so are you familiar with like Sting yeah
all right so sting clashes that used to
happen from the 80s all the way down the
one thing that I saw in dance hall
culture that I wasn't seeing in hip-hop
was the way when dance hall artists was
getting busy and clashing in front of
than
105,000 thousand people in that sting
audience the energy that they had to
have to make sure that they're
portraying themselves in a
way that was just more than the lyrics
It Was a a complete Showmanship that was
a collective of things it was the outfit
it was the jumping around it was the
kicking the foot it was the flinging
your hand and the way you was coming
through on the microphone and the flow
patterns and the the cleverness of the
lyrics and the punch lines it was all of
these
things and it was mindblowing to me
because I wasn't seeing that same thing
in Hip Hop in Hip Hop you seeing dudes
just walking around you know they might
hold their crutch and they act like they
too cool to be that
animated me I love that [__] I love kung
fu movies I love karate movies so all of
that
[__] and the dancing up and the dist and
and that and the foot this that I just
took all of that [__] and I said I'mma
turn this into what I'm gonna do on
these stages and I think
that if I master this [__] and I could
Master my
breathing and I don't exhaust myself too
soon try to jump around all over the
[__] stage going crazy I think I
might become a dangerous [__]
that's hard to compete with
because dudes are not moving like this
on no stage I'm going to all of the
shows I'm being a student I'm in the
clubs I'm in the street I'm everywhere
just to
see and learn and and and pull
inspiration from
somewhere and I pulled a lot of
inspiration from different places but
that was when I found it like looking at
those Clash sting clashes and jammies
and killer monjaro like all them man
from Saxon and all of that that was out
here Tipper I and all of them man like
them dudes raised me it's so interesting
because what you've described there is
kind of like my understanding of what
creativity is where you you pull from so
many different almost clouds of
inspiration to create a new one yeah and
I was thinking about I was thinking
about your kids you you said to me
before we start recording you got six
kids and they're around like 20 30 years
old now
right based on what you now understand
about what made you stand out different
the the what it took in terms of your
mentality to use the word student there
if one of those kids comes to you now
and says Dad what are the fundamentals
that I can take from your journey up
until that point at say 21 years old
that
would increase my chance of success no
matter the industry what are those
fundamentals so
the fundamentals that I would give my
kids which I've
already feel like I've been given to
them is the first thing is
identify with what you
love and once you love it hone in on
that thing until you can Master it to
the point
where people can identify that there's
no questioning your love for
it that's the
Thing Once you love it to the point
where your actions speak louder than
anything you could say about how much
you love it that is always the root of
whatever success is pre-ordained or
destined to come to you no matter what
it is that you choose to
do
because what is actually going to to
create the
revenue is that you're not doing it from
a place of trying to generate the
revenue you're going to do this [__]
regardless so it's not about the money
for you you're fulfilling
something in your soul in your body
there's a feeling that even the money
can't give you there's people that have
this money and they still can't find
that feeling man and there's nothing
like
it this is a feeling that really exists
bro that can actually make you the
happiest person in the
world that happens to be my
music
because and and my children understand
now I love my children so much and I
love my family so much
I'm not playing with anything that I
know is going to allow me the
opportunity to make sure that I can show
them and I can take care of them and I
can without compromise find a way and a
means to securing of the well-being of
my family and I found something that I
love that has provided me those means
and the ability to do it and I don't
have to question how I'm going to get to
that on no day I could be sick I could
be I could be sick and in the hospital
and write a
song and even if I'm too weak to say
it I could give it to
somebody and work out whatever business
I need to work out with that person so
they still do that same song God willing
the success of that song
that hopefully is garnished reaches a
level of success based on this creation
from a feeling that I was inspired by or
from a feeling that I got that I can't
explain and I can't give to nobody other
than through this
music that will take care of not just my
family but it actually might take care
of filling a space in the millions of
people's lives that will hear this [__]
that at some point depending on the
impact of the song they [__] around and
see you 20 years from now and become the
[__] CEO of Google and will tell you
I am a
fan I love you what this [__] song
did to for me when I was 10 now I'm
30 and at this moment when I was 10 I
remember wearing this little T-shirt
with a yellow [__] balloon face on it
and I had my my little bicycle
outside and my mother let me play with
my two friends two houses down we played
this [__] song 10 times in a
row until we had to go
inside and that song changed my life and
it gave me the motivation to want to do
this thing evolve into this person think
a new way that allowed me to pursue
something that I found that I love and
now I'm a [__] $200 million CEO and
Google I'm a fan of your [__] you're
still doing what I love and I want to
sit down with you and figure out
something magical that we could do
together sounds addictive that's very
[__]
addictive [__] that that's the most
addictive [__] in the world to me
because it's like that's that's greater
than man you can't teach somebody how to
do that that's not a book science that's
not
school you know what I'm saying that
[__] is you identify with this
gift we all got the gift this something
that we've all been blessed with at some
point if we listen to that [__]
little thing that speaks to us
inside some people call it Instinct some
people call it a Vibe some people call
it an energy whatever the [__] you call
it some people call it a voice whatever
that thing is bro if it Sparks the
thought
that changes the whole
trajectory to what your life can evolve
into because you took a second to listen
to that
[__] you are identifying with your
blessing you are identifying with your
gift and at that point you learn what
the [__] it is and become one with it
and walk in your purpose bro so you
might instill this thing into the lives
of so many
people
that you live forever through this thing
that you've created that's not a man
thing no more that [__] is deeper than
man I am absolutely addicted to that
because when you really think about it
that [__] is something that's that's
Godly it's weird to me when people find
it strange when we call ourselves gods
and Earths right because I'm
saying what do you want me to be you
want me to
be other than God anything other than
its original form is the worst state of
its own
existence because you're not even
functioning within the nature that you
was created to function in
so you can't make me call myself devil
likee because you think that it's a
Blasphemous act for me to say that I'm
God l or I'm Godlike or I'm made in the
likeness of the most high that mentality
is why I function this
way because I refuse to think that there
is nothing that I can't
do Beyond
man beyond man if I could sit down here
and smoke a spliff and eat a bowl of
cereal and [__] go
y
when I step up in the place and when I
step your steps correct woa got you in
check and the whole [__] planet is
doing it it don't matter what country I
go to and then I get to Sweden and they
telling me y y y yes yes yes yes yes I
ain't from Sweden I don't know that I
just was vibing and bugging out the weed
had me filling away nice little spliff
little food little bowl of cereal and I
just was joking in the crib and
Y [__] was laughing in my house
I thought it was funny I did this [__]
on the record I like funny but I also
like serious there's always a balance
between the guys that we found the most
entertainment from all of the dudes that
was on TV that we like that was the
[__] criminals they was always funny
right Al Pino and Scarface he was a
serious [__] but he was funny
Joe pesi and Good Fellas serious but
funny right we in the hood we love the
balance between serious and funny
I try to incorporate serious and funny
and all of my
[__] bottom line is my children the
fundamentals I want to give you all find
it love it identify with what you love
become one with that thing pursue it to
the point where you become so engulfed
in it you don't know nothing else other
than that walk in your purpose is what
it evolves into what kind of human
beings do they need to be character
traits all right this is what it needs
to
be some of it might sound [__]
up first thing is you got to be selfish
as
hell you gotta be
selfish I don't give a [__] it's it's
it's the it's to sacrifice but without
great sacrifice and without great risk
there there is no such thing as a great
[Music]
reward can't have one this that doesn't
there's no that math will never math
you know what I'm saying yeah you have
to have and I don't like this word but
I'm going to say it because it's true
you have to be a little maniacal with
the [__] maniac right that word isn't
good in a lot of situations but when
you're pursuing your destiny when you
identify with your destiny you have to
be selfish you have to be maniacal you
have to be
uncompromising
and you have to move in a way when it
comes to those three things where you
function completely in a way where it's
an unwavering Faith like it don't matter
how [__] up that [__] might look it
don't matter how much it feel like it
ain't gonna work
delusional complete
delusion you got to believe the
delusion because it's only delusional
until it
works so is it really
delusional a [__] only gonna
call it delusion until it don't
work for nobody else to see but for the
whole world to see and then once the
world see it there's nothing delusional
about it now your delusion becomes oh he
was a [__]
genius we didn't see it when he saw it
we didn't understand it when he did
we thought this [__] was crazy
but he definitely always he always
figured this thing was the thing to do
and he's he's stuck by that [__] when
you say selfish obviously that word has
got a lot of different connotations and
meanings and but I heard from it that
the selfishness is focusing on serving
yourself and your dreams and your
mission like you were somewhat selfish
when you said I want to be a rapper even
though your father's saying I want you
to come and be a electrical contractor
that was selfish of you to say no I want
to take care of me
first that's selfish I'm meaning even
more extreme than
that
yes selfish to my father
because and in a way I don't want to I
don't want to look at it as was selfish
to him I was just on some I don't want
to do what you want to do that's not
really being selfish that's just having
a difference in opinion right selfish
when I say selfish it means my children
right I've had to miss moments that were
never going to get back I missed my
oldest son's High School
graduation I
missed one of my daughter's College
graduations I've
missed times when I should have been
there to
teach my child how to drive or I should
have been there to teach
my child how to ride a
bike I missed a lot of that
right
and a lot of it had to do
with
circumstance and my circumstance which I
obviously contributed to creating for
myself I had to take responsibility for
these choices that I made and these
circumstances that I created for myself
and the the situation that became a real
life situation for me left me very few
choices so there was a choice where I
could be there for everything and then
the money ain't where it need to be
or I'm going to do what I love not just
because I love it and it brings me joy
and it brings me peace of mind because
I would go to the
studio and when I'm in that studio and I
close the door and then I'm in those
four
walls I don't have to argue with a
child's
mother I don't have to argue with my
woman I don't get talk back from people
that choose to have a debate about [__]
that ain't even worth debating about all
of the unnecessary
distractions I can leave outside of that
room and when I'm in that room I am
fulfilling my
destiny I am
fulfilling my soul and I'm making myself
get to a place mentally where my peace
of mind is so where it needs to be that
not only am I allowed to become feel
think and evolve into whatever place
mind takes me I'm then able to get to
that place emotionally spiritually
mentally create something put it in a
song change the effect that I can have
as an impact through this thing that I'm
blessed with as a gift and then I
could come down off of
that and be in a happier place so that
when I do get back around the people
that I got to argue
with I'm in a better place to deal with
them is there sort of guilt associated
with that as you've sort of matured and
and understood and you know had time to
reflect on missing those key moments I
worry about this a lot because I'm a
workaholic and I think my work is in
many respects some kind of psychological
Escape um and I I'm concerned that when
I do have a kid I've got a partner we've
been together four years I'm 31 now that
I might use my work as an excuse
to not be there or I might not make the
adj necessary adjustment to realize that
I only get one bike ride
moment so I'mma tell you
something there is no right way and no
wrong way when it comes to making that
decision other than what you know in
your
heart I definitely live with guilt I
feel like there was things that I could
have
done
without to be there for my
children but I also feel like that's me
saying that now
right I'm in a different place now in my
life than I was at that time and at that
time the mentality that I have now
didn't exist then right
and the mentality that needed to exist
then
for me to get to this mentality now was
important and it was a part of the
needed components to exist in my journey
for me to be able to have this
conversation now this mentality now was
that survival it definitely was
survival when you dealing with four
mothers all having you in court systems
all getting significant amount of money
for child
support all all not in the best place
relationship wise with
you sometimes business is up sometimes
business is
down you have to be able to be Swift and
changeable regardless of the
circumstances in order to stay
remain because no matter if business is
up or business is down the courts don't
care the child support that needs to
come every month the mothers need to see
it cuz they don't
care when your kids need what they
need they don't
care because they didn't ask for
this you can't create an
excuse that's how I was
raised your kid didn't ask to be put in
a situation that you cannot do what
you're supposed to do for them so this
not their problem you have to find a
solution it's a little of pressure it's
a lot
it's a
lot but I also feel like when you
identify with your
gift that's part of the gift that's what
makes it the gift because the most high
usually don't give us more than we can
handle you know and with that being
said all of these things we talking
about which is one of the best questions
that I love that you asked right what
would I give my kids and I keep coming
back to that because I want my kids to
understand
understand that focus on what you love
is most primary being selfish and when I
say selfish not just my kids but even my
woman there might be a lot of [__] she
want to do
sorry I can't do it right
now I can't do it right now I could do
it later and then there's moments when
you can do it and you make the time and
you do it you know but until there's
another means of me being able to do
what I love and find the Fulfillment
that I find while I'm doing what I
love this is also a part of who y'all
fell in love with I want to talk to you
about one of our sponsors LinkedIn job
super quick because without LinkedIn
jobs the dire of Co team simply wouldn't
exist how it is now I've probably hired
about 90% of our current team through
Linkedin and I wasn't just looking for
CVS as you've seen in my posts I've
never cared about CVS I was looking for
passion expertise dedication and above
all else kind people which tends to be
really hard to find on job sites
typically but with LinkedIn jobs you're
not just getting a CV dump it's like
walking into the world's biggest
networking event if you're a small
business I get it we're juggling a
million things often without the luxury
of the HR department but LinkedIn makes
the hiring process intuitive smooth and
super efficient they've even rolled out
a new feature using AI to craft job
descriptions for you for greater
efficiency so here's my tip to you if
you're looking to hire the best
professionals make your life easier and
use LinkedIn jobs and right now for our
diio community you can post your job for
free at linkedin.com doac that's
linkedin.com doac terms and conditions
apply let's talk about Zoe who you may
know because they're a sponsor of this
podcast and I'm an investor in the
company you guys know health is my
number one priority Zoe's growth story
has been absolutely incredible so far
they're doing science at a scale that
I've never seen before because of their
and recent breakthroughs in research
they can now continue to offer the most
scientifically Advanced gut health test
on the market previously the test
allowed them to analyze 30 bacteria
types in your gut but now thanks to new
science they've identified 100 bacteria
types this is a huge step forward and
there's nothing else that's available
even close to it on the market at all so
to find out more and to get started on
your Zoe Journey visit zoe.com
stepen you can use my exclusive iive
code
ceo1 for 10% off don't tell anybody
about that okay just for you guys
moments in our life I think help us to
see things a little bit more clearly and
especially when they're really um
significant moments and one of those
moments that I see in your story is in
2012 um where I think you're 42 years
old at the time and your manager and
friend Chris
dies rest in peace to Chris Chris was
all that I
knew everything everything that I I
learned after Chuck D and Hank shock and
them I learned it with Chris I learned
how to make my money with Chris my tax
brackets changed with Chris my lawyers
changed cuz Chris my booking agents
changed with Chris my touring
experiences changed with Chris my
ability to tell my mother to quit her
job and never had to look back to work
for nobody from 1995 to this day all of
that I did it with Chris that day when
you find out that Chris's
ped can you take me to that
day that day was so [__] terrible
bro
wow his life changed when this woman
came into his
life I'm not going to dive too much into
that part
but I'm definitely going to say that
Chris's life changed not for the better
when she came
around
so once that happened it started to
change the energy amongst the Violator
family and I really wish because I don't
want this to be heard in a way where it
seemed like I'm [__] on the woman
because I'm not [__] on the woman
I'm acknowledging the reality of the
situation as you can see I'm not saying
nothing bad about the woman I'm just
talking about I'm I'm
acknowledging a time period where a
change transpired in a significant way
and it happened after this woman came
around that's it long story
short I think his daughter was was
coming home from college and he he had
to go and meet her at Grand Central
Station in
Manhattan
so he asked me for a ride to Grand
Central
Station and
um I give him the lift to Grand Central
Station and that's the last day that I
saw
him the next morning
I get the
call from his
assistant that something happened to
him and I'm asking what happened to him
and they just said he hurt himself but
they didn't say you know that he was
dead they just was like he he hurt
himself the assistant called this young
lady I forget her name at the office and
when the young lady answered the phone
we're on the
three-way and she's crying and she's
screaming on the
phone
[Music]
and she just kept saying Chris hurt
himself Chris hurt himself and the
assistant is asking her what exactly did
he do to
himself and she said she don't know he
just hurt himself
and then we asked if if he was dead and
then she she said she don't
know so when we got to Chris's
[Music]
home we couldn't go in the house and
uh it wasn't
until you saw the coron van come
and when you saw the
van and then they revers the van into
the
driveway to get us close to the
door of the
house it was a downstairs door and then
there was the regular door to go up the
stairs and you go in the house from the
front but whatever happened to him it
happened
downstairs cuz that's where his body was
and they went
inside and they um they brought them
black bags with them them body bags and
uh that's when it that's when it got
real that's when it changed everything
changed when you
saw you saw the
bags and
uh we knew um
when they came out the
uh when they came out the basement with
the bags and his body was in the
bags that's when you knew Chris was
never coming
back so
uh you know the crying
started and a lot of arguing
started
a lot of threats
started and
uh my life was going in a whole another
Direction after
that and I didn't like
it cuz I was confused about how to
move and I was lost for a
minute because
uh
I never really had to manage my career
without a
manager and he wasn't just a manager he
was my
brother so it got scary for a
minute I couldn't get it together that's
why I didn't put on no record for nine
years and
um I started to just do different type
of for business with signing artist and
uh
um that's when we put out OT
Genesis and
um we had some really good success with
him and
um signed a few other artists you know
this one artist by the name of stove
stove God cooks and I
signed you know another Young artist by
the name of murder Mo
and I
um I wasn't happy though with with just
doing it like that and I just I didn't
feel comfortable putting out music until
I got the right support system in place
and I I couldn't get it
together when you say you couldn't get
it together what does that what does
that mean that means like
psychologically you couldn't get it
together psychologically I couldn't get
it together because I didn't feel like I
had a support system that I could
believe enough to make me feel like I am
psychologically able to move with the
Comfort the confidence and the support
that I know I'm going to need and the
responsibility of trying to wear all the
hats myself I was doing it but I wasn't
doing it at the level that Chris light
was able to do it and you were grieving
at the same time absolutely because I
lost my father two years after
Chris the two most important male
figures in my
life Chris was gone 2012 I lost my
father
2014 and you had reconciled with him
before I definitely reconciled with him
before he passed the problem
is I didn't get to enjoy my time with
him once we got good so that was was
horrible feeling
too because it's
like all of the time that was wasted
[__] not getting along was was
stupid [__] stupid you know what I'm
saying that's part of the reason why I
started to really like get unhealthy and
[__] up I was trying everything to
drown the pain and the frustration and
the
suffering of those lost
is about overworking over drinking over
smoking weed and
cigarettes and it got so bad that I got
to the weight of 340 PBS I never been
that I'm I'm not even built to be that
heavy it's it's funny it's like I look
back at certain pictures and I looked at
how overweight I was I look at my skin
yeah there's certain pictures I had I
had these like like marks on my
face I I hate those pictures like I see
the darkness in those pictures yo
there's this book called The Body holds
the score but the title is just the
thing that I I I've I've actually gained
the most from it just says that when
there's things going on in our
psychology in our mind the body will
show it yeah man we'll eat we'll drink
we'll won't sleep but you'll see it in
the body before you see it in the mind
the mind is invisible obviously right
the body is the first place to see it I
was reading through that phase of your
life and you were on sort of breathing
machines when you were sleeping and
things like I wasn't on a breathing
machine I had sleep AP sleep apnea yeah
yeah I had sleep apnea I was um you
drank yourself into a coma at one point
I drank myself into not a coma I drank
myself into an inability to wake myself
up oh okay I had to be W woken up by my
son and my security in La it took like
45 minutes and we had just come back
from hanging out at a club called
poppies he sat me down the next day he
was like
listen I don't want to hurt your
feelings cuz you're my
father and I don't even know if I got
the strength to say it to you now but I
had a conversation with the
security I need you to listen to them
because I'm too scared to tell you how I
feel that's how bad it
was my son ain't never speak to me like
that in my life but I needed to hear
it but he couldn't even say it to me
because that's how much he still was
trying to protect my
feelings but this is the first time that
I knew I really disappointed my
son all that Bust Around [__] was cool
up until this
moment when he saw this [__]
and he's been seeing it but this is when
it hits the low that conversation [__]
me up the next day the doctor with the
pregnant on and I went to the doctor I'm
breathing so [__] up that outside of
the door the doctor was like
yo why you breathing like that and he
wasn't even in the room with me he's
coming in the room and I said breathing
like what because I was doing it this so
for so long over the last three years
that I was it was starting to sound
normal to me the doctor said I'm sending
you to the hospital cuz he stuck this
[__] in my throat and when he saw how
big the [__] palps was it block 90%
of my breathing
passage he said if he sends me home and
I take a shower and the central air
system is blowing and I catch a draft
that can lead to me catching a cold and
that last 10% of my breathing gets
blocked up because of a swollen Gren
from a sore throat or some [__] I can
die in my sleep that night
he said I got to call an ambulance for
you I'm in California La he says I need
you to go right now to UCLA Medical
Center into the emergency room and I'm
going to call the head person at the
hospital to have them admit you
immediately you need to go into surgery
tomorrow I said I ain't going in no
ambulance he said well then you have to
sign this document that will exemplify
me if you don't listen and something
happens and you die between now when you
get to the hospital I ain't never been
spoken to like this in my
life this is when I knew this [__] was
crazy my son now I'm calling him telling
him to meet me at the hospital we get to
the hospital and I'm in the doctor's
office and they doing all the
preliminary [__] before they got to
admit me into the
emergency my son is talking to me and he
tells
me
I thought you was gonna die last
night and I ain't never been this scared
dad but I'm I'm scared you're gonna die
I lost Grandpa already I can't lose you
too can you please stop drinking can you
please stop smoking can you please get
back to the daddy that I know you to
be finished me
at that
point I made up my mind I'mma get this
surgery when I get this surgery I'm
going to get in shape I go home on the
way home Dexter
Jackson bodybuilder competitor used to
compete in the Olympia he
became a Mr Olympia champ this man pops
up in my
stories driving in his car and Jackson
Ville Florida and he's spitting the
vocals to put your hands with my ask
could see and then I hit him in the DM
and I said Mr Jackson I'm a huge fan of
you as a professional
bodybuilder is there any way that we
could get on the phone I need your
help he hits me back he sends me his
number I call him on the
phone I
said thanks for calling me I salute you
Mr Jackson can we please figure out a
way to get me back in shape and man said
to me you saw you ready bus and I said
absolutely he said you got to come to
Jacksonville and you got to stay here
for 30
days tell your girl she can't come tell
your kids you'll see them in 30 days I
need to put you through something for 30
days before we continue this journey you
survived this 30 days I know you
serious I rented a [__] Mansion
for like seven bedrooms I would have got
a cameraman to documented my meal prep
Chef my masseus cuz I knew that that
workout was going to [__] me up every
day and I needed somebody to rub these
muscles up I got my recording engine in
so I didn't need to leave the house I
got an
assistant
and that was about it stayed in the
[__] crib for 30 days lost about 27
pounds in 30
days these
dudes that I'm surrounded
by by way of my first bodybuilding
competitor trainer Victor Munoz and my
second primary trainer the legendary Mr
Olympia himself Dexter Jackson I was
able to get my [__] together
bro and once I got my health and once I
got my mind and I got my spirit
right and I started to be proud of me
when I looked at me and my kids was
looking at me and they would say [__]
that you could only
hear once you did what you needed to do
and put in the work you needed to put in
so that it
shows they not g to say it if it don't
look like the way they need to see it so
they could say what they need to
say when that happened
you hearing the right [__] you feeling
the right love that [__] was lifting my
spirit so much and then I'mma tell you
something going through this pandemic
was another serious challenge mentally
and emotionally and
spiritually my brothers farel Williams
and swiss Beats
and big up to Timberland too because all
four of them is the executive producers
of this new album Blockbuster which is
out right now absolutely the Blockbuster
album is out and I'm super grateful to
everybody that participated in helping
this magic happen and come together this
is this is the culmination of all of the
experience and all of the life stories
that we've talked about but the thing
that really stood out to me is you've
made the decision to put people on this
album who are young upand cominging
fresher artists who you haven't really
worked with previously and you've worked
with like everybody everybody but you
chose to give these younger artists the
platform for some
reason two
reasons the first reason is I'm never
gonna listen to The Narrative of this
thing
where I would hear
it a little more regularly than I
actually choose to hear it actually
don't ever want to hear it but it's this
[__] about how the Elder States or
the older MC's don't really respect what
the new guys is doing that [__] is
[__] at
least speaking for myself and the the
type of artist that I surround myself
with we don't feel like that and we
don't move like that we encourag that
[__] because when we was young artists
we wanted the big dudes to put their
arms around us and give us game and
schoolers and teach us [__] so we could
be better you know what I'm saying Chuck
D gave me my name daddy Kan used to let
me come to his crib and ask questions he
put me on his albums he used to help me
learn let me learn bring me the shows
that he was performing at [__] um De
La Soul they did the same [__] for us
like too many MC's gave us the guidance
that made me great I feel like it's only
right that we do the same [__] for the
next generation of [__]
especially if they dope and I'm a fan of
a lot of these new artists
and I want to work with them because
they still inspiring me to want to go in
the studio and stay razor blade Shar
with my [__] when I got to do my [__]
you know what I'm saying and I see a lot
of them paying homage there's a lot of
[__] walking around with their
hairstyles like how I used to wear with
my drad there a lot of [__]
that dress and they throw their heavy
jewelry on that do it the way I used to
do it and still do it I just ain't got
the dredge No More but all that other
[__] we still doing it but I just want
to make sure that they they know when're
not only here to give them the answers
and the mentorship and the guidance and
the information so they could be that
much more sharper when they're being
creative or when they're sitting in the
[__] corporate office negotiating a
deal with the lawyers and their managers
but I also want them to know
that we love them too we're fans of what
they doing we see y'all paying homage
and we want y'all to know we paying
homage to yall too one of the things I
always think is destined to own the
future is when the when both the past
and present come together and I say that
with all due respect because sometimes
people see projects like this as you
passing the torch but what you're
actually doing is sharing the flame
sharing the [__] flame you couldn't
have said it better cuz I ain't I ain't
putting flame out no time soon you're 33
years deep in it's still you're still
selling out the shows and doing the
Arenas and killing the game and I I'm
I'm so excited by this project because
for those reasons because you have you
have two sort of generations coming
together to create the future and that's
what's so exciting and I have to say
from this conversation everything you
say and understanding the man that
buster is put so much more meaning into
the lyrics into the album and the
records so everyone needs to go check
this album out right now wherever you
stream anything please go check it out
because it's one hell of a project and
you're you know you talked about that
Google CEO who you inspired when he was
10 years old you were that person and
you still are that person for me thank
you King so it's such an honor to have
to to get to spend this time with you
today thank you brother likewise man for
real the questions you
asked the places you went I didn't
expect it I'm glad I wasn't prepped I'm
glad I wasn't prepped I'm glad you know
what I'm saying I just was given a
prerequisite of how important you mean
in this space in your platform and
congratulations to
the your Evolution and your success with
what you've been able to create for
yourself thank you and becoming a
successful businessman I was driven and
inspired by the story that I was being
told about you and I was like oh no [__]
that I got to come pull up and I'm
taking my time I appreciate because
we're gonna do this [__] properly and
I've never done an interview in 33 years
never done an interview interview this
in depth number two I ain't never sat
with nobody this [__] long and
did no interview in in Europe in my life
neither so you you got you hold a record
bro I appreciate you honestly it's the
it's one of the greatest honors of me
ever getting to do this is is hearing
that from you so thank you so much B
thank you it's an honor and a pleasure
brother appreciate you
[Music]
King a quick word on hu as you know
they're a sponsor of this podcast and
I'm an investor in the company it is
finally here 3 years of work from here
to try and make a bar a snack bar that
is nutritionally complete as of the
recording of this episode they finally
released these bars that are high in
protein 27 vitamins and minerals and
just two gram of sugar The Impossible
has been done and it tastes so godamn
good often these snack bars these like
high protein snack bars taste like
you're eating Play-Doh or cardboard or
something it's so hard to make one that
is nutritionally complete and that
tastes good and ladies and gentlemen
here we have it I'm going to put the
link in the description to get your bar
below try it out and tag me and let me
know exactly how you get on because it's
so nice to finally have a bar that is
nutritionally complete and that actually
doesn't taste like cardboard and that
tastes
delicious The Impossible has been
accomplished as you know because I've
been sent thousands of messages these
conversation cards sell out
exceptionally quick so here's the deal
I'm going to make with you if you join
the waiting list which is in the
description below you will get sent
access to buy these conversation cards 1
hour before anybody else they're in
limited Supply so if you really do want
to get your hands on them please do add
your name to the waiting list in the
description below and you can find that
waiting list at theconversation
cards.com but I'll also include it in
the description below wherever you're
listening to this episode